[музыка]
друзья а я вам Напоминаю что партнёром
нашего гемба подкаста является компания
Marine Health которая завозит японские
БАДы Кто не знает БАДы - это
биологически активные добавки которые
помогают здоровью ваших сосудов а также
повышают ваш иммунитет принимайте БАДы Я
сам их принимаю Вы знаете я фанат Японии
и даже не столько Японии сколько
японского качества
поэтому я доверяю японским бадам
покупайте принимайте следите за своим
здоровьем Да пребудет с вами
энергия Добрый вечер друзья Итак мы
начинаем наш очередной МБО подкаст А это
уже второй сезон третий выпуск нашего
гемба подкаста время летит незаметно
быстро К сожалению а с годами оно
быстрее бежит ещё быстрее что достаточно
сильно огорчает пожилых людей типа меня
Ну вот мы как раз-таки сегодня поговорим
об этом мы поговорим об энергии о том
как управлять энергией Как сохранять
восполнять прекращать утечку энергии и
об этом всём мы поговорим с нашими
гостями которые сейчас сами представить
себя по нашей традиции и дальше мы
начнём нашу тему но до этого я хотел бы
Напомнить вам ещё раз что гемба подкаст
это подкаст где мы собираем не экспертов
мы собираем бизнесменов деятелей
искусства культуры
спортсменов интересных людей с которыми
можно было бы сидеть вот так за столом и
просто как вы на кухне общаетесь точно
так же это кухонные Посиделки но с одним
исключением что мы говорим ни о чём
попало а о конкретной теме которая
интересует наших зрителей А второе что я
хотел бы вам напомнить что слово гемба
Что значит слово гемба Дело в том что в
кай технологии
которой я являюсь существует такое
понятие гемба гемба - это то место где
произошла проблема или то место где
принимается решение о том как решить эту
проблему обычно если взять это
производственное предприятие проблемы
происходит в цеху так вот начальники
поднимают свою задницу идут в цех и там
в цеху разобравшись с проблемой там же
принимают решение поэтому мы не случайно
назвали наш подкаст гем подкаст это то
разра пробле и принимаются решения кухня
кухня Итак поехали слево направо Всем
привет Благодарю за приглашение
Малич имею честь здесь находиться Меня
зовут амаж Дамир Я являюсь
предпринимателем также общественный
деятель и также сейчас являюсь Член
Совета по Молодёжной политике при
президенте
республи Привет меня зовут Сергей
Романович Я в прошлом активно снимался в
кино сейчас предприниматель блогер
путешественник миру ЭРТ Я являюсь
профессиональным спикером и возглавляю
ассоциацию спикеров СНГ в Казахстане Ну
и также учу людей не просто говорить а
говорить так чтобы их услышали и слышали
профессиональный
бизнес-тренер всем Ассаламу алейкум Меня
зовут амн тумов Я
предприниматель У меня два проекта
смежные первые - это строительная
компания но здесь мы как бы представляем
узкую нишу вентиляцию всё что связано с
вентиляцией и второй проект - это
производство стеновых приточных клапанов
это такие коробочки которые стоят возле
радиатора для того чтобы свежий воздух
всегда поступал в помещение и это
напрямую зависит от этого напрямую
зависит энергия То есть если в помещении
нету кислорода то энергии неоткуда
браться на любом мероприятии на любом
подкасте можно говорить
потом ещё я
писатель моя книжка я написал книжку
детскую 10 ПС Томас и тайно семейного
амулета сейчас Продаётся в сети Меломан
поэтому милости просим ещё композитор
едал написал написал ги для ка
клуба всё это благодаря чистому воздуху
всё это благодаря маленькому
прибор Вы приручите рядом с батареей и
он даёт
энергию очень Классное начало на самом
деле алимджан очень ещё по пути хорошо
продался то Чем он занимается А и связал
это с энергией на самом деле всё можно в
этой жизни связать с энергией всё вот на
самом деле Трудно представить что даже
материальные объекты это уже учёные
доказаны что расстояние между
микрочастицами просто там космические
масштабы
А я читал что если брать микрочастиц
ядро - это как булавочка а Электрон от
него на расстоянии вот Представьте
стадион Лужники на последнем
ряду Электрон а ядро в центре поля Да А
этот Электрон находится на последнем
ряду в виде теннисного мячика и вот это
вещество так говорит это вещество или
пустота в основном получается пустота и
получается этот мир больше энергии
нежели
вещество Я наверное криво объяснил Но
даже вот
это об Смотри вот этот стакан Да это
кажется это кажется твёрдым веществом Да
но если брать молекулы э этого стакана
дойти до его атома и ядра так вот
расстояние между ядром и электроном
будет как между теннисным мячиком и
булавочки на стадионе Лужники То есть
получается Он весь состоит из пустоты и
отсюда учёные говорят что мы всё-таки
этот мир - это энергетический мир весь
он состоит из энергии вообще нехватка
энергии - это становится глобальной
проблемой в мире это тема Очень
актуальная Причём я не говорю про
энергию тепловую там электрическую и так
далее это вот именно наша жизненная сила
жизненная энергия У меня есть статистика
воз за двадцать первый год я думаю она
даже всю картину не отражает Здесь
пишется 280 млн человек страдают от
депрессии и упадка сил Ну зная своих
знакомых знает тот круг общения
и видя как многие люди действительно там
уходит в прокрастинацию апатию депрессию
и так далее Мне кажется эта цифра точно
занижена Ну как раз мы сегодня об этом
поговорим И просьба к нашим зрителям
тоже Напишите если это как-то с вами
связано Если вы сами видите что
действительно людей потерявших жизненные
силы и энергию много напишите свои
случаи либо Скажите поставьте плюсики
Хоть это и не вебинар но тоже какая-то
активность Итак первый вопрос Расскажите
Были ли у вас ситуации когда у вас не
было энергии и
вы попадали в депрессию или может в
апатию или были на грани этого у нас
смотрите порядок за слом такой первую в
первую очередь Если хочет высказаться
девушка Она имеет приоритет Как классно
да она она может говорить всегда и много
а так как нас Т мы будем брать
количеством она будет брать временим
потом по
возрасту да потом потом по возраст са да
са самый молодой Итак рве я начну скорее
всего сразу маргулан Калиевич с боли
которая знакома большому количеству
женщин я буду говорить с позиции женщины
и с личного моего примера Я помню 2018
год август месяц у меня за спиной 12 лет
как у меня уже была компания я как бы
казалось достаточно известный тренер
своей отрасли но я просыпаюсь своей
новой Вт комнатной квартире я понимаю
что я ничего не хочу делать я по сути
позитивно настроенный человек конечно в
своей трёхкомнатной кварти которую ели
достигла дала что тебе ещё делать на тот
момент Казалось бы потому что если знать
мою историю то она как раз начиналась
работы официантки и уборщицы квартиры
поэтому для меня это Казалось бы на тот
момент большое достижение и я помню
когда я проснулась утром и и думала что
по базовым потребностям я уже закрыла
Всё я стала для общества успешной если
взять профессия реализация но у меня не
было сил двигаться и это было как раз
вот это понимание Я тогда поняла что вот
это оказывается называется депрессия Ты
когда утром просыпаешься А тебе пусто и
ты делать ничего не хочешь тебе не
интересна ни Твоя компания тебе не
интересна ни работа Ни базовые
потребности которые ты закрыла которые
раньше были важнее тебе А ещё из за
спиной развод то есть сейчас я
оглядываюсь назад я понимаю что когда мы
живём в какой-то го
за потребностями которые мы закрываем
для себя картинкой успеха то мы думаем
что вот вот ради этого мы и живём и
когда человек теряет Вектор вот этот
баланс о котором вы кстати говорите и
говорите про счастье и про состояние
внутренней удовлетворённости ко мне это
пришло лишь только тогда что оказывается
я бежала за внешней картинкой которая
мне наложило общество что если я была
когда-то уборщицей квартир надо было ми
Тебе же надо было стать успешной стать
номер один общество кричало финансовая
твоя независимость это номер один то
понимание о внутреннем состоянии его не
было То есть я очень много работала ради
вот этой внешней картинки То есть ты
считаешь что ты пережила депрессию да да
и ты считаешь что основная причина твоей
депрессии была в том что ты гонялась не
за теми целями Да за навязанные целями
когда ты не понимаешь внутри что для
тебя в жизни действительности важно И
когда ты приобретаешь Казалось бы вот
эти все внешние твои навязанные
обществом потребности но нет внутренней
целостности то теряется смысл жизнью
оказывается Для чего я бежала развод
уставшая проблемы в бизнесе Ну да есть
имя Да есть Крыша над головой Да есть
дети а для чего и на этой позитивной
новости мы пока остановимся смотрите
первый у нас Первый раунд такой мы
рассказываем истории про депрессию
апатию попадали не попадали а во втором
раунде будем рассказывать как мы из
этого выходили всё у меня всё А давай
Дима до Мих а Доми
Олег Сегодня мы все
да хорошо что я одна девушка не
испу девушка не спутать да на самом деле
это такой не то что тяжёлый вопрос я в
депрессию не попадал вот такого я не
считаю что это была депрессия вот да не
попадал Ну хорошо Почему Потому что
не знаю вот последний год я начал
замечать У нас есть социальный проект
Вавилон тинц немного предысторию
расскажу у нас там дети от 7ми до 17 лет
у нас есть дети это социально бесплатный
проект где я прокачиваю навыка там детей
софт skills навыка ораторской ско
переговоры продажи навыки Там
арт-терапия они прорабатывают папу маму
Ну такой долго рассказывает Суть в том
что сейчас у нас дети типа 10 лет и ему
говоришь А что тебя там что ты не
делаешь он говорит я выиграл Возможно у
меня депрессия 10 лет Да и ты такой
смотришь 10 лет ты у кого услы это и в
последнее время вот в обществе начало
такое слишком
много такого Да я перегорел я в депресси
Я выиграл у меня принцип такого как бы я
мужчина я не могу перегорать выгорать
когда у меня есть ответственность семья
и так далее и я просто вот я вообще сам
на русского похож да вот даже Дима меня
назвали Я чи чистый казах Я чистый казах
Да 5 лет назад я тоже принял не то что
принял
скоро Судя по внешности тоже да я тоже
рыжий раньше был наверное этот местность
наверное перекрасила меня в чёрный вот а
5 лет назад я был атеистом вообще такой
атеист с Бога не верил бывший военный
Бог это нет Бог Бог Бога нету матери
нету Есть Родина Вот но 5 лет назад
пришёл в Ислам тоже долгая история
Просто проснулся начал читать внутренний
голос пришёл просто в один момент Ислам
сейчас практикующий а можно сказать
мусульманин и вот с того момента я
Просто там любое слово да что-то у меня
случится я просто там говорю альхам Ха
Да это всё по воле Всевышнего не ищу
такое знаете типа может у меня депрессия
может у меня выгорание Надо подумать
Надо подумать может у меня выгорание
что-то не так и как бы всё сразу вот Ха
альхам значит так должно быть я мужчина
У меня есть ответственность семья и всё
изза этого у меня возможно нету
депрессии Классно да ты с какого региона
с Алматы
местные прямо отсюда с поколения ко есть
казахи у меня вот в основном это
Восток на востоке много казахов
голубоглазых рыжих много а у меня
ситуация такая в X веке когда монголы
нападали же мы за границу монголы Да
уехали ты помнишь да на берегу
нагу на берегу грец отдыхали и потом
монголы на шествие что-то прошёл они
вернулись смотрят здесь уже всё уже
смешалось с мангалом думают ладно здесь
останемся вот с тех времен остались
здесь а классно
чистокровный чистокровный это он те
сказал что мы не чисток тролит всех нас
да вы же назвали меня Димой моя ответка
Да хорошо Серёга твоя история принимай А
так моя история Ну я попадал много раз
попадал и из таких самых ярких Ну ты
наверное как творческий человек
творческие люди я они в этом подвержены
я думаю да то есть я-то ещё ходил помню
когда мне было лет наверное там 19 когда
учился вгике снимался в кино слушал там
грустные песни Высоцкого по парку Ходил
плакал и думал что вот я такой
гениальный поэтому я должен страдать
Ведь все гениальные люди Они страдают
они плачут я себя этим
тешился вот история с тем что я ислам
принял на какой-то момент там всё
поменялось потом как-то опять даже
религия же в какой-то момент для
человека становится обыденным е
обыденной вещью если он каждый раз своё
сердце не обновляет скажем так не
укрепляет и я попал в такую тоже жёсткую
апатию когда я жил в хостеле Хотя уже
снимался там и в кино и деньги были но я
жил в двенадцати местном капсульном
отеле в одной из капсул просто ничего не
хотел ложился спать в 700 утра был Вот в
Москве в Москве был Да вот в
Алмате капсульные отели есть да да там
есть капсульные отели и я говорю вот
люди кто меня узнавал То есть я меня
показывают в кино Там по ТНТ а в
кинотеатры выходят фильмы и тут там
выходит парень просто и видит как я из
капсулы такой вылезаю с утра он вообще в
непонятках что происходит Да и он думает
что ты здесь делаешь вообще вот потом Ну
я говорю у меня такой период был когда
мы вот наверно На протяжении года я
ложился спать там в 78 утра спал там до
45 выходил гулял опять Вот так до 7 утра
тусовался ничего не делал Вот и этот
жёсткий был такой период у меня и тоже
вот в Америке недавно я так получилось
что я там полетел в Америку был там
полгода поехал Без семьи сам и первые 2
месяца жил в коливинг в хостеле тоже там
но там уже было вос мест я пошёл на
понижение и я 2 месяца тоже ничего не
делал Я просто вот в этой капсуле
просыпался сидел там вылезал только
поесть сходить в уборную намаз почитать
и всё и обратно в эту капсулу и Ну потом
расскажу как из этого вылез Но вот у
меня такие периоды они несколько раз
были когда я проваливался просто вот в
жесточайший апатию когда ты у тебя вроде
бы всё есть да как мы говорили А ты
ничего не хочешь думаешь зачем Для чего
чтобы что и ты такой просто вот просто
спишь ешь И всё И вот весь твой как
каждый день Вот так примерно происходит
так что да я я там был рядом сели как
раз один никогда не был а другой ветеран
можно сказать мне то что интересно вот
если брать там казахских Батыров Да там
00 год 00 год они тоже интересно были не
не пойду на войну в юрте си депрессии
наверное Или вы горани у меня было или
такое обсуждение тоже я думаю у всех
было мы же знаем что говорили даже что и
пророк печали в какой-то момент да или
там люди
начинали печалиться или у них там Вера
слала поэтому я думаю это доста ты
просто не даёшь себе в неё посмотреть
Может ты так её берёшь так она только на
так хряще убираешь её с дороги и пошёл
Алга может быть мы придём до причин ан
Ну смотрите если брать 365 дней в году у
меня наверное В году есть 10-15 когда
Просто мне не хочется ничего делать я
там дома лежу валяюсь А так как у
Дамирова У меня тоже там таких депрессий
никогда не было потому что я
практикующий мусульманин уже лет 20
наверно около 20 лет поэтому то есть вся
моя депрессия там в пятикратном намазе
Ты когда в сада ложишься там жалуешься
делишься советуешь и так далее То есть
как таковой депрессии У меня тоже
никогда не было Слава Богу у меня
четверо детей там мне не до депрессии па
стучаться У меня депрессия у меня
наоборот энергии много я вот поэтому и
вступил в клуб потому что как бы
окружение тоже есть такое которое там
тебя не поддерживает где-то А здесь я
нашёл Блин настоящих таких друзей
единомышленников мы там с ними за этот
год вот ровно год будет как я вступил в
Каз клуб мы куда только не ездили батур
только не ездили и На Балхаш Кстати а
так много где были с одноклубниками
поэтому Депрессия это мы взяли крайность
апатия депрессия А тепер давайте
поговори горим о том что является
причиной утечки энергии вот Назовите вот
я классифицировал пять вещей Первое -
это люди а второе - это ситуации третье
события четвёртое - это действия
какие-то и пятое - это время потому что
я заметил своё время что у меня в
какое-то время энергии всегда много
утром какое-то время всегда мало Ну то
есть вот в вашем случае что
является источником утечки энергии Не не
мы не говорим про сейчас апатию
депрессию апатия Депрессия - это крайне
Когда ты уже максимально истощённые
фокуса на на теле то есть мы же на на
тело же внимания не обращаем на
состояние тела и мы просто тело
используем используем используем Мы же
не делаем практики Ну как кроме спорта А
другие расслабляющие техники Мы же не
делаем для тела Мне кажется когда мы
перестаём обращать на тело тело просто
даёт сбой и всё и и утечка энергии вот к
тому что вы добавили Ну
это тело сбой даёт она в каком случае ко
бывает когда ты делаешь что-то Не то
отсутствие радости это же тело даёт
признаки не не я считаю так тело - это
условно орган который теряет энергию
либо приобретает энергию но сами причины
- это люди когда ты общаешься с
негативными людьми ты теряешь энергию
когда ты - попадаешь в ситуации бывает
негативно раз в аварию попал оба ты
теряешь энергию бывает действия которые
у тебя высасывают энергию ты делаешь
какие-то действия Ты же заметь во всех
этих случаях тело работает Ну вот а Вот
как раз ты не обращаешь внимание
насколько оно у тебя Ну в состоянии
таком напряжении чаще всего и это тоже
утечка энергии Потому что когда человек
а расслабляет максимально своё тело и
убирает напряжение в теле тогу даже
сталкиваясь с неприятным человеком он
считывает с тела информацию что сейчас у
меня идёт какая-то такая реакция и он
управляет своим телом сохраняет свою
энергию то есть я говорю мы очень мало
фокусируется на то как чувствует себя
Наше тело Ну вот в твоём случае Скажи
что что у тебя забирает энергию Ну у
меня забирает энергию Вот как раз люди
ситуации которые вы проговорили которые
происходит которые ты не ожидал там
например
вот более конкретно вот более конкретно
Ну например вот сейчас только вот перед
тем как выехать сюда у меня были 2 часа
консультации передо мной сидят спикеры у
которых высокий уровень напряжения То
есть это это настолько они напряжены и
когда ты им даёшь разъяснение как
выстроить их речь они тебя не слышат они
очень напряжены И вот я ощущаю что я
начинаю реагировать на них их же
напряжением и соответственно у меня
происходит утечка энергии и я в этот
момент делаю вдох-выдох я говорю так
подожди это их напряжение на себя не
бери их напряжения и я начинаю осознанно
говорить замедленным голосом и не брать
их напряжение на себя Потому что они
высоко напряжены и соответственно когда
они мне говорят свои мысли они с вот
этим высоким уровнем напряжения начинают
меня цеплять Угу а моя задача в это
время считать А что со мной происходит и
Я прямо чувствую что я прямо у меня сил
не остаётся с ними дальше
коммуницировать я делаю вдох-выдох
внутренний и говорю так подожди подожди
это их картинка Это не моя и я начинаю в
своём ритме с ними работать Угу И потом
Пока к вам ехала в такси там сделала 5-7
минут
А ещё что вот у тебя в течение дня Что
забирает в течение дня Ну вот сейчас я
пришла к тому что у меня мало Что
забирает вообще энергию потому что я
убрала токсичных людей со своего
окружения Я не иду в проекты которые мне
не нравятся я больше делаю то что мне по
душе и поэтому Ну может быть когда на
слойка много работы Ну там например вот
сейчас консультация потом консультация
потом ту Да ехать когда большой объём
работы
впивается Угу
альжан Ну я тоже Что забирает энер Что
тебе не нравится Что забирает вот после
которого ты вот как выжатый Да тоже
такого редко у меня бывает Я даже не
могу вспомнить
сегодня ли заряженные Не ну токсичные
люди однозначно можешь Подсказка как
жить когда очень много энергии
Да вода
заряжена людьми Нет смотрите Марч
Например у меня мобильный телефон
забирает вот энергию я сейчас вот
подумал и я вот сейчас пытаюсь себя там
ограничить пос восьми выключать но никак
не получается вот мобильный телефон за
забира в мобильном телефоне смотри
Алимжан мобильный телефон - это просто
железяка и со стеклом там наверное
всё-таки что-то другое что-то ну нет Да
не знаю вот просто жалко время жалко
времени вот то что я время трачу на эти
вещи А мог бы там например там Дея
энергию забирает действие не
продуктивные действи не продуктив де
правильно говори то есть ты скро
там в помещени нет кислорода свежего
возду а у него дома хорошо установлены
этики
конечно кислородное голодание
просыпаешься
углекислым
Гам Ну по поводу энергии Наверное если
вот то что вы всё назвали на самом деле
есть да это самое главное это Общество в
котором окружении ты находишься Угу важ
приходишь и там все ноют один ноет
второй ноют там третий ноет ты начинаешь
уже об этом задумываться погружаешься и
таким же становишься да гадже де 100%
успеха - это окружение Но если затронуть
тему это наверное долги Мне кажется это
долги именно вот если брать общество Да
это всё все кредиты Да там наверное 50%
на Кас Каспи аккредитованы наши Да там
точно то
долги Почему Потому что на самом деле
сам в такой ситуации был и общество мы
так тоже вот такие открытые без завтраки
проводим и так далее У всех вот проблема
вот говорит я не могу начать потому что
я боюсь почему боюсь начать у меня
забирает энергию начинает долги если у
меня вот долги у меня есть Например я не
могу из-за этого ни вправо не сделать ни
влево не сделать я не открываю бизнес
потому что у меня есть долги я это не
делаю потому что у меня есть долги у
меня э энергию забирает соответственно
человек как бы на это обращает внимание
потому что для меня энергия - это
внимание Угу вопрос Куда ты отправишь
своё внимание если ты хорошая хорошее
увеличится Если плохое плохое увеличится
но трудно да контролировать когда у тебя
есть плохое Вот трудно делать хорошее
делать вид что ничего типа не происходит
когда О тея да да когда у тебя есть там
долги или что-то плохое и как бы ну как
с вами же говорится там всю жизнь Ты
будешь бороться с самим собой только Да
И вот как бы человек реально сам с собой
борется постоянно и побеждает тот кто
вот реально прям пытается фокус
перевести на хорошее Этот человек растёт
но большое общество большое количество
людей в обществе перекидывает именно на
негатив вот на эти долги и
соответственно как бы уходит в минус Я
считаю что это самая большая номер один
проблема в обществе это правда Это
правда
проблема заёмщиков И вообще людей у
которых есть долги в том что у них
взгляд всегда обращён не на то что у них
есть а на то чего у них нету И они
соответственно ВС внимание у них
направлено на нехватку на дефицит на то
что у них у них не возможности погасить
долги значит нету денег соответственно
они только думают о том чего у них нету
у них нету денег больше внимания они
обращают на это соответственно денег
становится ещё меньше поэтому долги
реально это большая катастрофа в
Казахстане Особенно с этим
закредитованность населения это большая
проблема так Серга У тебя что самое
основное что меня забира
[музыка]
этония потому что убеждения же формируют
и окружение вокруг тебя и действия
которые Ты совершаешь убеждения сделать
так у тебя будет либо праведный контекст
либо негативный действие целевое или
нецелевое поэтому это вот фокус настроен
или не настроен всё вот с точки зрения
убеждений а именно что ты хочешь Да к
чему ты идёшь как ты свою жизнь
устраиваешь Какая у тебя вообще есть
миссия Потому что когда нету убеждений
человек Он же очень много энергии тратит
на то что в нём сидит куча амбиций
которые он не не реализует Угу и очень
часто люди страдают тем что он говорит я
чувствую что во мне потенциал есть но он
ничего не делает и от того что ничего не
делает Это его изнутри разрушает он
сгорает и как раз проваливается вот в
эту бездействие апатию потерю сил
энергии потому что мотор то он работает
и он как бы такой А давай давай что-то
сделай а он ничего не делает и он просто
из-за этого у него внутри начинается как
бы вот ещё когда
молодой молодой юски максимализм когда
вырост ты начинаешь жалеть это тоже У
тебя забирает ти а Блин не успел а не
сделал Интересно что в молодости а у
людей амбиций много а возможностей мало
И вот этот разрыв между амбициями и
возможностями страшно бьёт на человека
соответственно вообще механизм Как
происходит и Механизм Долгов тоже Кстати
а у человека по молодости много энергии
много амбиций а возможностей мало но
человек хочет достичь большего из-за
этого он идёт кратчайшим путём он не
может развить терпение
он не может основательно о чём-то думать
он стремится Он спешит и когда спешит он
срезает углы он берёт долги он берёт под
не доработанный проект инвестиции
привлекает необдуманно и в конце
залетает долги он берёт кредит в надежде
что ото бьётся там быстро и так далее И
вот это всё приводит вот основа вот я
соглашусь с тобой Серга что убеждение
убеждение осно вот в этом плане Ислам
конечно оберегает от многих ситуаций
депрессии апатии от основ потому что
Ислам формирует правильное убеждения в
исламе же говорится что Аллах
вознаграждает за две вещи за принятие
риска и за проявление терпения приходит
за это поэтому это важные вещи насчёт
Долгов ты классно сказал мы два
предыдущих подкаста посвятили именно
долгам долги - это на самом деле така
такой большой бич общества когда человек
имеет долги ни о чём по-моему другом
думать не может особенно если через день
ему присылают эсэмэски
коллекторы там я даже не представляю как
можно о чём-то думать о чём-то
позитивном Ну при
этом мы на прошлых подкастах когда
говорили говорили о том что мы к
сожалению
переоценивают заключается в том что люди
не платят долги да не платят не
возвращают долги да но при этом у них
чувство долга то есть они себя в ловушку
загнали что долг это настолько всё плохо
что вот надо вернуть надо но сами при
этом не возвращают сами деньги тратят на
что попало Но вот это чувство долга их
давит и один из Советов у нас как раз
таки был расслабьтесь Идите к кредитору
если не можете выплатить скажите что не
можете
выплатить но при этом скажите что у вас
есть главное проявите Покажите намерение
то есть дол что-то такое
незыблемое даже Конституцию вон сколько
раз меняет что говорит про кредитный
договор Идите и Договаривайтесь с
кредитором Это вопрос переговоров
кредитор же тоже не идёт просто с вас
выжимать соки если у вас тем более их
нету Предлагайте план вместе обсуждайте
кредитор - Это первый человек который
готов заинтересован Да где-то
заинтересован Вам подсказать
посоветовать Как выйти из этой ситуации
и ищите решение у кредитора вообще есть
такой хороший лайфхак вообще на будущее
Наверное всем интересно будет что всегда
выход из любой ситуации находится там же
где и
вход кажется Мистер Очевидность Да ну
смотрите это как помещение вот вход
дверь с той стороны когда заходишь ты
заходишь через дверь Вот она дверь но и
выход тоже через дверь то есть там где
вход там и выход соответственно если ты
попал в ситуацию Долгов изза кредиторов
то и выход из ситуации через кредиторов
Вот это очень жно помнить Поэтому всегда
обращайте внимание Или например
вы попали в какую-то ситуацию из-за
которой вы теряете энергию
соответственно и выход там же
разберитесь в этой ситуации Почему вы
теряете энергию раз Вы в эту ситуацию
попали вы попали туда не зря то есть
главное всегда помните в любой тяжёлой
ситуации выход находится
там где вход Как вы в эту ситуацию
попали туда идите
ра далата вот так долги тают на глазах
очень классная книга там ну книга
сколько там листов 300 вот всё описывает
до детально прям все моменты вот тогда
мы всем рекомендуем так как у нас
сегодня подкаст не про долги но долги
Кстати
а так как мы говорим в мире всё энергия
то деньги - это тоже энергия
соответственно когда ты взял у кого-то
взаимо энергию и должен вернуть с
процентами эту эту же энергию Поэтому у
тебя не эги это знаете Это как говорится
сейчас хейтеры в комментарии могут
писатели всегда говорить типа конечно
Вам же легко говорить У вас же нету
Долгов вот самое распространённое сло
Поэтому нам легко и говорить поэтому и
нет Долгов потому что мы знаем
как По молодости у всех были долги я
думаю да здесь тоже чудеснее происходит
По молодости были у меня Прим были
различные ситуации где возвращал долги
ситу где за сч переговоров были ситуации
где мне кредиторы помогали закрыть долги
то есть открывали какие-то новые
возможности подсказывали что-то и так
далее всяко бывало я не говорю про не
счесть ситуации где мне были должны Я
почему эту ситуацию более-менее хорошо
знаю потому что я был и на этой стороне
и у меня должников очень много и я знаю
Вот откуда энергия
[смех]
Что забирает
энергию в
жизни не бывает такой ситуации когда вот
вы дошли до точки какой-то при которой
всё вы перестаёте терять энергию совсем
А даже если вы смотрите если вы не
теряете энергию это очень плохо энергия
происходит застой энергии она
превращается в дурную энергию в дурную
вот мы здесь плавно переходим к
следующей теме как восполнять энергию и
вот один из методов восполнения энергии
вот видели наверное практику когда Ну я
со своими учениками в прошлый раз э мы
шутили Горная река там а-а над горной
рекой мост и я говорю повернитесь к реке
повернитесь это к горам на раз д три Все
кричим и там фраза и мы кричим а прямо я
говорю Вы должны выплюнуть лёгкие ну так
называемое у Угу И они потом и у вас
будет полегчает вроде какая-то ту топо
тупой приём Но работает жёстко люди
приходят у них давление повышается
потому что они на напряглись давление
повышается
они как бы более бодрые
выкрикнула возбуждается так вот смотрите
это выброс негативной энергии и очень
важно Так если ты энергию не
расходуется и превращается в негативную
а негативная энергия начинает поедать
тебя самого Поэтому в энергии есть такое
хитрость чем больше вы её тратите тем
больше её у вас появляется Вы же ходьбу
сами практиковали да е Я занимаюсь
всякой фигнёй вот я пытаюсь загрузить
себя полезными делами Но когда нет
полезных дел между ними я Вставляю любую
активность либо причём активность это не
только физическая это и ментальная и
эмоциональная активность Ну лишь бы
чем-то всё время заниматься я ещё
заметил такого мужчины наверное
подтвердят что мужчины сливают дурную
энергию когда ездят вот я в доме долго
сижу не могу мне надо на машину сесть
поехал по степи та или даже по городу
Поездил такое ощущение что женщинам тоже
нравится моркока да музыку особенно
громко включил а потом сама же поёшь под
эту громкую музыку и на машине очень
хорошо
становится проезжает пробки
создают хочет сказать не слыши зна
пешеходов не
видит вся хитрость управления энергией
заключается вот в ЧМ вся хитрость
управления заключается Том что со
временем Убрать всё что у вас энергию
забирает но при этом самому тратить
энергию туда куда ты хочешь Вот люди
неосознанные они что делают они живут
целый день и у них целый день забирают
энергию не он отдаёт а у него забирают
ту энергию и из-за этого он ходит такой
как жертва его все Разде банили он домой
приходит весь выжатый как лимон а так
как я достаточно пожилой уже человек я
всех потребителей энергии отрезал выбрал
те направления куда я хочу тратить
энергию и сам добровольно трачу энергию
но суть остаётся всегда одна энергия
должна уходить это суть другой вопрос
она Уходит потому что у тебя её забирает
или потому что ты её тратишь туда куда
хочешь ты сам Вот и вся разница поэтому
у меня мало кто забирает энергию но
очень много куда я трачу сам
поэтому контролируйте Кто у вас забирает
энергию Что забирает Какие ситуации
Какие действия события и так далее
сокращай Выберите отберите и в случае
вот с теми же
соцсетями я отписался от всех От всех у
меня в Ленте только то что я люблю там
техника гаджеты там
какие-то философские ве и так далее и у
меня нету
новостей По новостям э недавно прочитал
исследование такое что
а говорится чем реже вы смотрите новости
тем объектив нее у вас картинка и там
рекомендовали не читать новости чаще чем
два раза в месяц два раза в месяц мы
читаем каждый час по 10 раз наверное да
вот поэтому чтобы удерживать себя от
этого я просто снёс все новостные
ресурсы это знаете одно упражнение
сейчас я быстро сделаю посмотрим вот
вытяните правую руку в перво писе правую
Да все вот кто тоже в зале вытяните
правую руку перц Покажите указательный
палец указательный палец Вот это типа
про Вот это знаете типа как бы в
новостям Но говорят вот Покажи
указательный палец такие Да нами не
манипулирует мы всё слышим Это потому
что на автопилоте на автопилоте Всё
происходит вот по поводу убеждений мне
вот понравилось на самом деле Вот сейчас
Э по поводу убеждения тоже с этим
сталкивался это вот когда бывает же люди
у тебя забирают забирают когда ты
соответственно становишься для других
полезен люди у тебя забирают забирают
там хотят кого-то пригласить что-то тебя
получить никто никто не готов давать
тебе взамен я сейчас позиционирую себя
как Нетворк это человек который имеет
Знакомство со всеми Вот я со всеми
знакомлюсь Ну вот интересно в нетворкинг
есть такое понятие когда ты можешь быть
полезен ты уже вот например я там
встречаюсь с человеком человек хочет от
меня что-то получить моё убеждение что
не он хочет что-то от меня получить я
ему сам уже хочу это отдать и получается
от этого я наполняю когда я несу пользу
и вот я себе миссию там 5 лет назад
когда вы Сам пришёл миссию прописал что
я хочу быть причиной успеха для 100 млн
людей И когда человек от меня что-то
хочет забрать моё убеждение если
например он вампир будет убеждение
вампир я потеряю от эту энергию если мои
убеждение будет от того что наоборот Я
этому человеку хочу быть полезным то
тогда соответственно я для него причина
для успеха Значит от этого Я заряжаюсь
потому что человек после этого там
что-то меняется у него мышление меняется
он тебя благодарит и ты понимаешь что ты
выполняешь свою миссию и вот это
убеждение вот у меня уже несколько лет и
как бы по такому принципу и идёт что я
раньше тоже так думал блин одни вампиры
там вампир я такой вечером прихожу
кажется
истощает или вот это сидишь анализирует
но когда понял что Наоборот ты пользу
несёшь уже нет такого истощения каких-то
вампиров вокруг уже как бы ты уже этот
иммунитет выработал вокруг себя что ты
наоборот отдаёшь ты не ждёшь пока тебя
укусят Ну там же встречаются люди
которым ты отдал А у тебя такое ощущение
что ты в одни ворота бьёшь а он Ну вот
следующее убеждение ой следующий момент
то что я всегда отдаю и забываю Потому
что если я жду взамен исходящий поток не
работает потому что я жду что-то взамен
типа что-то дал и такой жду жду жду раз
человек не отдал мне я начинаю
Разочаровываться потом разочаровывать
других
разочаровываюсь Катины мир это я создал
Да смотри здесь один есть нюанс Кстати у
меня есть этот мастер-класс
называется Кадер нетворкинг Посмотри
если будет интересно смыс заключается в
том что невон - это настолько важная вещ
Я говорю нетворкинг - это такой же актив
как ваши заводы фабрики станки оруд и
так далее а у 99% людей это не
нетворкинг это просто записная книжка
полное знакомство А в то время вы должны
это превратить в актив так вот смотри
какая ловушка в твоём случае Дело в том
что ты очень правильно управляешь своими
убеждениями а но у любой ситуации есть
две стороны есть объективная сторона
объективной реальность есть твоё
отношение к этой объективной реальности
так вот в объективной реальности есть
дождь снегопад солнце и так далее ты
изменил свою картинку и говоришь для
меня любая Погода
хорошая любая Погода хорошая и ты дождь
снегопад всё понимаешь и вампиров не
вампиров и негатив ков нытиков всех ты
воспринимаешь хорошо но проблема вот в
чём Если ты хочешь быть эффективным то
ты должен понять в технологии есть такое
правило качественного сырья ты никогда
не сделаешь качественную продукцию А из
качественного сырья ты имеешь шанс
сделать качественную продукцию то есть
ты должен понимать что только из
качественного сырья так вот если ты
будешь работать со 100 миллионами
нытиков Никакой пользы ты им не
принесёшь А это ты будем так говорить Ты
им не принесёшь ты больше себя убедишь
что Ты приносишь пользу Поэтому моя
рекомендация твоё отношение к внешним
обстоятельствам это классно но всё-таки
внешнее обстоятельства учитывая с кем
общаться и желательно негативных э
нытиков людей которые всё время жалуются
которые не винят
себя в том что с ними происходит а они
всегда будут перегружать на тебя вину
они сами не несут вину Они на тебя будут
грузить я хотела донести это
потребителей вот Бывает же такое
постоянно потребительское отношение Ты
как солнце Даёшь Даёшь Ну мы же не все
родились исходящего потока Угу все
когда-то были тоже потребителями я сам
был потребителем Я работал в 2017 году
нет поменять не хочу Нет Т вопрос
служения если человек это определяет для
себя как вот у меня знакомый есть Имам
Асхад там Московской мечети и я просто
не представляю сколько к нему приходит
людей постоянно спросить причём не
просто прит как дела а люди там свою
жизнь делятся а как вот с точки зрения
религии А как это и он всегда на жёстком
позитиве потому что я понимаю если бы он
своё отношение к этому если бы он не
чувствовал что это его миссия что он
допустим ра няет тем самым религию он бы
уже умер выгорел Да просто действительно
когда ты А там же сколько людей Возможно
невежественных у которых низкий уровень
понимание не то что там религии себя
даже они могут такие вещи писать звонить
совсем это подскажи а это можно а это
нельзя А здесь что это учёные говорят А
что это учёные
гово
это миссию Да если подробнее уходить я
это как сделаю вот ко мне человек
подходит говорит вот как поймать
мышление как вот это сделать как вот это
сделать а человек условно Да вампир Я
ему говорю У нас есть суббота вот
субботу уже 4 года ни одну субботу мы не
пропустили по традиции У нас вот в
амфитеатре в субботу в 10:00 утра в
смартпос все крутые спикеры выступают я
приглашаю спикера арендовал за свой счёт
зал говорю Приходи туда хочешь
поменяться приходи туда Покажи свои
намерения в 10:00 утра Угу Или например
если человек говорит Вот я хочу там что
бывает же совет такой он долгий та ты не
можешь с ним разговарить я говорю в 8:00
утра горельник если человеку это нужно
вот сразу Давайте скажем а каждую
субботу в 10 утра 10 утра в смарт поинте
мы проводим разные открытые мероприятия
разного формата в ту субботу у нас были
продажи бесплатно бесплатно беплатно Так
что кто хочет мастеркласс изменить своё
мышление кто вообще хочет расти по жизни
пожалуйста добро пожа Да И вот реально
просто люди ещё же видят они же всегда
вот даже у нас есть люди которые видят
думают там какая-то Выгода там всё равно
вот знаете он что-то будет продавать там
отвечаем мастер-класс какой-то Я говорю
Ну хорошо прийдите Убедитесь они
приходят убеждаются и этого нету вот так
сидят в конце А что вы нам продавать не
будете я говорю здесь никто не пришёл
продавать Здесь вы пришли менять
мышление вот как бы мы вот такой фильтр
сделали и вот всех Приходи в 10 утра и
уже отфильтровать да Вопрос полюбому
если если это вопрос миссии это да Вот в
этом плане Сергей хорошо подметил
когда люди выбрали это миссией то им
действительно без разницы кто перед ними
негатив нытик не нытик и так далее и так
далее Это это правда да И если ты так
делаешь Это это очень круто на самом
деле но для этого нужно ощущать что это
твоя миссия Что ты будешь делать и
давать только в одну сторону и не ждать
Абсолютно никакой благодарность это
очень такая тяжёлая ниша и ноша но при
этом ты подпитывается тогда из других из
духовных источников вот я же говорю
позици себя как общественные деятеля в
плане что я же как-то пришёл в Ислам это
же тоже не просто так ну сейчас не
пропагандируют мы там не было такого
сейчас мы как Буто там Ислам Пропаганда
Пропаганда
бы на исламофобия же знаете когда у нас
же в Казахстане лют же Ислам Навязывать
А ислам это любовь это же пример себя и
человек на тебя смотрит и говорит А как
ты так изменился ты говоришь Ислам Он
говорит О я тоже хочу а не так что
хочешь измениться Иди в ислам вот не
таким убеждением И вот когда 5 лет назад
я пришёл в ислам вот я начал идти таким
принципом И вот я с этого пути уходил
раз пять вот реально уходил и меня Бог
по башке несколько раз давал вот Каждый
раз когда уходил он меня долгами
затягивал бизнес Всё хорошо идёт раз я
говорю всё у меня есть деньги Кураж
Мотоцикл куплю короче бабашки Бах короче
минус 30 млн я такой Как так у нас
стратегия Как так что-то не так
начинаешь копаться вот как говорит
откуда зашёл оттуда и выходи пришёл на
свою миссию служения Начал опять же
завтраки мы проводим всё сообщество
собираем людей мотивируем на грель ходим
раз Деньги идут идут долги закрывать
только думаешь наверное Случайность
короче опять уходишь опять раз по башке
по башке И последнее у меня было Вот это
в том году в мае а не Да в том году в
мае прям Бах по башке ударили я такой
всё-всё больше не буду я на своём месте
То есть когда идёшь по своему пути тогда
будет и Энергия и деньги больше такое
знаете изза этого как бы Кстати это один
из главных лайфхаков
Да самый главный источник потери энергии
это отсутствие смысла да когда ты не
видишь смысла в своей жизни когда ты не
видишь смысла в своей деятельности
в работе в том Кто ты есть у тебя всегда
будет минус энергия не будет энергии А
когда у тебя осмысленно Ты понимаешь
свою миссию Ты знаешь для чего ты живёшь
зачем зачем ты что-то делаешь энергия
всегда приходит энергия вообще в целом
всегда приходит Если у вас есть ответ на
вопрос
Зачем Если у вас есть ответ на вопрос
Зачем энергия автоматически даётся
энергия как материнское молоко она
даётся так по мере по мере того как ты
понимаешь находишь смысл жизни и свое
дете Вот так мы среди детей тоже делаем
сейчас же это вот мы у нас методологии
своей с детьми же работать надо я раньше
не работал когда начал всё изучать вот
год нашему проекту и мы добавили очень
много методолога психологов и психологи
говорят там методологи говорят раньше
разрыв поколения было 10 лет сейчас
разрыв поколения 3 года Ну типа там 2010
смотрели Маша Медведь 201 там смотрят
уже там Смурфики 2016 смотрят это
хагиваги да И они уже не понимает между
ними там возраст 3 года и они друга не
понимают мы раньше мешали типа детей там
8 и 12 лет И мы их в один добавляли
допустим в одну группу и они там Занятия
проходят и они вообще дру не понимают
контекст разный ты думаешь В чём причина
оказывается Вот вопрос возраста 3 года
вот мы начали по 3 года вот детей делить
и у них сразу был контекст и теперь по
поводу мотивации вот мотивацию мы начали
им давать что вот ты причастен мы начали
вот служение обществу потому что я моя
цель в вырастить общественный деятель
мне говорят Какая твоя цель у тебя вот
500 детей Да сейчас это ты там бесплатно
ты деньги свои тратишь там привлекаешь
где-то спонсоров Какая твоя цель я гово
моя цель чтобы больше общественных
деятелей стало это людей которые несут
пользу обществу и не ждут что-то взамен
тогда говорю внутренне внутренне среди
общества Мы будем быстрее расцветать а
не ждать что-то от государства Да что
внутри мы сами будем быстрее двигаться и
вот у нас дети реально вот мы говорим ты
причастен к этому благодаря тебе Ты
мотивирует дети Да там вот ты на
грейлинг придёшь другой ребёнок тоже
увидит твои одноклассники увидят какой
ты крутой Да и он приходит дядя Дамир
Вот мы там на грель к в воскресенье
сходил я в школе всем рассказал Все
говорят как так ты молодец там в 7:00
утра и вот он как будто вот чувствует
что он причастен к нечто большему Да вот
то есть перебивать причастность детей с
детства мы сейчас вот ещё перебьем можно
минуточку мы вот добавили волонтёрскую
группу внутри волонтёрскую и вот то что
мы сейчас мероприятия проводим как раз
форумы проводим и получается мы вот этих
внутренних детей задействуем в разных
мероприятиях говорим вот ты причастен к
этому форуму благодаря тебе этот форум
проводится если ты ты там не будешь ему
там 15-14 лет 12 лет он уже мотивируется
он уже понимает что он то чтото хочет
как бы создаём вот этот образ это
классно а давайте Мы перешли уже на
вторую часть как вот выходили мирт мы не
дослушали как ты справилась со своей
ситуацией мне помогла практика на уровне
тела я просто включила ранние подъёмы я
вставала в 5:00 утра и делала часовые
практики йоги То есть я начала с тела
потому что голова не работала то есть
она ничего не воспринимала А сейчас а
сейчас просто нет в тот момент когда я
просто в тот момент просыпалась в 5:00
утра и вот целые где-то Я месяц каждое
утро
практиковалась состояние поменялось
соответственно я приняла решение сделала
действие и вышла потому что состояние
депрессии ничего не дела поддер ну
поддерживающие действия есть я имею в
виду ну я Да да да сейчас а не сейчас
обязательно у меня ежедневно есть
утренние практики
ра это я говорю про тот момент про самый
трудный момен я
вол Да к истории вернулись как ты
вылезла кстати хороший лайфхак тоже для
наших зрителей Дело в том что Учёные
доказали когда человек Даже у него нет
настроения если он просто улыбается
Через силу 15 минут Улыбайтесь просто и
у вас настроение автомати
То есть можно можно идти через какие-то
там духовные там ещё какие-то вещи а
можно идти через тело вы просто
приводите тело в порядок начинаете утром
вставать холодная вода очень классно
действует но здесь кстати работает не
только холодная вода больше наверное
выброс гормонов адреналина тестостерона
эндорфинов и вы такие чувствуйте себя
счастливыми Поэтому если вы попали в
апатию депрессию и вас нужно заво
вытащить самих себя
а рано утром Вставайте ходите либо
бегайте обливать с холодной водой
делайте это кажды каждый день и сами не
заметите как те улыбаться Да Улыбайтесь
Улыбайтесь и ложитесь 10:00 вечера и
по-моему через неделю у вас уже начнёт
всё налаживать однозначно это один из
способов Сейчас 10 минут Улыбайтесь Кто
смотрит и потом Напишите в комментариях
прямо в конце подкаста помогло или нет
Как настроение
так и есть Вот например я там 40 лет я
начал бегать до этого я вообще не
понимал как они бегают вот в чём прикол
бежишь бежишь 40 лет начал бегать
пробежал там ну вот полумарафон я
записался потом Его отменили на пандемию
но медаль Я получил 21 км я пробежал и
вот например вот как и вы Я каждый день
хожу 7-8 км каждый день потом душ и блин
энергия она сама куда-то непонятно идёт
и то же самое мы сделали вот вчера в
горах Вот мы были все Заур багдаш Мы
встали там в сторону Вот это ущелье и
давай орать каждый там а Спарта там
багдаш там кайдзен кричал и вот на самом
деле вот этот какой-то выброс вот этой
энергии Блин вот сразу легче становится
кстати хорошая фраза для того чтобы
кричать слово Ура Это инстинктивно да
две гласных посередине р а р создаёт вот
эту вибрацию д
бежаниц а когда Потому что когда ты
производишь гласно у тебя а наиболее
широко открыта глотка Ты можешь прямо
лёгкие выплюнуть Поэтому вот слово Ура
оно во-первых с одной стороны несёт
позитивный оттенок Что ура - это радость
с другой стороны это три буквы которые
легко вырину чем Кан два слога Да Ась
один слог всего и наиболее раскрыть
глотки с вибрацией
Ура и у тея это дурная энергия вылетает
поэтому Кто готов
попробовать к этому слишком серьёзно не
отношусь но
ю ещё Например у меня гитара я вечером
там прихожу на гитаре чуть почу всё
сразу же у меня это такой баланс энергия
раз с каждой струны энергия мне через
пальцы заходит потом дети дети там
поцелуешь детей покусаев там помучаю
Полежишь там поиграешь это тоже энергия
У меня например я как начал так Кати
книги писать каждый день Я каждый вечер
Я им читал книги читал потом рассказывал
потом придумывал и потом когда начал
придумывать блин получается да И вот
написал То есть благодаря это тоже же
энергия от детей идёт и получается ты им
Сказки рассказываешь они когда
придумывал сочиняешь
они не засыпают они наоборот на кровать
там садятся знаете что я придумываю и
такие мне щё подсказывают а не давай
лучше они да такие
соавторы здесь важно отметить такую вещь
о чём мы пока не говорили и вот для
наших хейтеров которые скажут вот
какие-то странные приёмы говорят Мы
сейчас в кучу набрасывая все лайфхаки
для всех ситуаций потому что конечно по
классике если рассказывать о том как
восстанавливать энергию начинать конечно
надо со смысла жизни с меси Для чего вы
родились потому что не ответив на
главный вопрос в вашей жизни все
остальные потуги - это только временные
заплатки поэтому смысл жизни для чего вы
пришли на этот
свет Для чего вы живёте что у вас будет
по утрам и так далее служение миссия -
это важные вещи Но помимо этого есть
такие заплатки лайфхаки которые здесь и
сейчас быстро можно применить мы их тоже
поэтому мы наваливаем в одну кучу но я
здесь с вами хотел бы ещ поговорить
такой вещи вы знаете вот с годами Я
заметил такую вещь что существует три
основных вида энергии физическая энергия
она понятна да А большинство людей
понимает физическая энергия есть нет они
уставшие или нет второе - это
эмоциональная энергия вот у вас есть
различия Что вы чувствуете свою
эмоциональную энергию я по крайней мере
чётко
чувствую вы назвали
Три ментально духовно Да духовно
четвёртое это как самый высокий уровень
да А я ошибся четыре да А ну вот у вас
есть разделение вот на виды энергии есть
есть эмоциональную сразу ощущаешь потом
ты управляешь этим эмоциональной
энергией своей потому что она потом
может влиять и на На многие другие аспек
это наверное больше про людей да про а
мы-то нет прох людей которые сат энерги
ситуации же всякие же бывают это и люди
ситуации это восприятие
энергия ко сам не она может быть у тебя
и высокой и низкой эмоциональной
энерги у меня ничего не у меня всё
о выпуск смо я просто думаю это всё
взаимосвязано То есть если грубо говоря
духовная энергия на низком уровне то ты
как бы там лайхаки не придумал не
придумал у тебя будет очень
запас этой энергии маленький то есть ты
так покал какими-то практиками себя типа
реабилитировать А всё как бы если клубок
разматывать то конечно взаимосвязано Я
считаю если духовная энергия на низах то
человек какие бы практики не делал он
всегда будет в одну и ту же как вот в
замкнутом круге в одно и то же место
приходить и так думать так как энергию
поднять так как энергию поднять потому
что это же как скверно и мы знаем что и
пророк если так можно говорить или
просто благослови Да приветствует он же
даже дуа каждую ночь читал Дуа от лени
потому что понимал что это напасть и мы
знаем что если Всевышний не займёт
человека чем-то полезным его обязательно
займёт Дьявол Да
безделица этот есть такой персонаж
мемный Кама пули он говорил типа
безделье - Это игрушка дьявола Ну вот
реально так и есть что когда ты
бездельничаешь ты всегда обязательно
делаешь что-то плохое ты в безделье
никогда ничего хорошего не сделаешь
Априори будет это против тебя Поэтому я
считаю что Да если духовной энергии нету
то что бы вы не делали каки Какие
практики бы там не придумывали не
кричали бы сколько там в горах ура там
ау или ещё что-то всегда ты потом такой
раз тебя обратно это развернёт поэтому я
да я чувствую что ну взаимосвязь То есть
я начинаю понимать по себе что у меня
видимо духовная Энергия пошла на спад
если я здесь сейчас проваливаюсь Да там
в своей апатии в депрессии это значит я
в самом Ну вот на самом высшем уровне
допустил ошибку Ну смотри а если у тебя
например физические истощение то тебе не
хочется лень читать намаз и так далее
тоже Здесь тоже есть связь между
физической например энергией и духовной
связи то что пря вообще там ломает тебя
ну поэтому это и есть как признак
лицемерия чело Например почему здесь
Значит нужно поднимать и вот этот не я
говорю то что в хадисах пришло то что
один из признаков лицемерия что человек
лениво встаёт на молитву утрене Ну
неважно Даже если он с неохотой идёт на
молитву Это говорит о том что у него
проблема значит с Ну
вот я имею виду что может быть такое что
именно от того что ты где-то физически
истощение получил и у тебя и как бы
здесь лень тоже может быть Ну я считаю
что ещё бывает болезнь то есть именно
как потому что есть же люди депрессия
именно на гормональном уровне у них
действительно вот с точки зрения
биологии проблемы он да он может быть
там и допустим супер соблюдающий и
верующий ещё что-то но у него просто
реально гормональный фон такой что он ну
не выгреба по этому поводу в исламе
говорится что чем сложнее тебе читать
намаз но ты идёшь читаешь тем больше
вознаграждение Если ты зимой на улице в
холод в метель Мороз вот мы на
Килиманджаро во сходили и ребята
говорили мы уникальная ситуация была 45
человек самая большая группа и мы два
рекорда там побили это была самая
большая группа И 100% зашли на
килиманджара и гиды Ну удивлялись А мы
потом когда спрашивали для фильма Почему
все Дошли все друг на друга ссылались
Кстати это как раз проявление силы
сообщества все друг на друга
и не с если бы один слился там несколько
человек сразу отпали а говорит мы
смотрим девчата идут нам перед девчатам
неудобно девчата гово нам перед ребятам
неудобно кто-то говорит нам перед это а
там несколько человек говорит а мы
смотрим татешка Ну моя супруга
ич на вершине в холод Мороз намаз читают
Мы подумали да Ну они ещ и намаз читают
это больше вознаграждения Я к тому что
вот вопрос Серёга возвращаюсь к вопросу
Ты вот разницу чувствуешь между этими
видами чувству Ну я чувствую по себе Вот
я я например э по эмоциональной энергии
у меня сильно развито Вот это ощущение
физическо я думаю каждый человек
понимает когда он устал эмоционально так
как я вынужден очень часто много
выступать а Я выступаю выступаю и могу
как машина работает работает работат и
через недели две я чувствую всё мне надо
в степ Угу одному и даже я знаю где у
меня дырка в эмоциональная энергия у
меня между лопаток Я чувствую холод
между лопаток и мне хочется всегда
прислониться к тёплой печке Я машину
сажусь
включаю отопление Это не возраст а это
не
возраст может быть это
уже Чуст ноги
замерзают сам деле на самом деле я даже
когда заболею в таких случаях бывает что
когда эмоциональная энергия падает
иммунитет тоже быстро падает поэтому я
сразу начинаю чувствовать что где-то
начинают заболевать да я сразу ложусь
там прошу супругу или массажист камни
нагревают и мне между лопаток ставят и
как будто дырку заткнули то есть вот эта
потеря эмоциональной энергии Я очень
сильно чувствую когда ты вот людям
отдаёшь энергию отдаёшь отдаёшь вроде с
точки зрения физики я мог бы ещё дрова
пойти колоть
там гири Поти
физики энергии много а эмоционально
чувствуешь что всё уже дальше не можешь
А бывает интеллектуально вот я бывает
иногда так
э эмоционально устал ещё один кстати
хороший лайфхак для того чтобы отдыхать
меняете смотрите Какой вид энергии у вас
истощают там пешком походить либо дрова
поколоть либо физическо что-то сделать
либо спортом особенно если дурная
энергия пошёл грушу поколотил Там и так
далее ментальная после ментально хорошо
заходит физическое физическое упражнение
либо там эмоциональные Послушать хорошую
музыку Я вот пишу когда курсы уроки я
пишу я могу провалиться там и 4-5 часов
пишу пишу пишу пишу пишу пишу пишу
чувствую когда дело сделал Но уже голова
просто это и тогда я та Я люблю
включаю музыку вот и через эмоциональную
энергию в это время ментальная энергия
отдых идёт такой клас поэтому хороший
лайфхак всегда смотрите Какой вид
энергии у вас
истощённые что-то скрупулёзно вычитывать
Поверьте мне у вас будет спад ментальной
энергии у вас
пойдёт упадёт концентрация вот как
восстанавливать менталь энергию вы
знаете вся ментальная энергия суть
ментальной энергии только в фокусе в
концентрации Как узнать что ментальная
энергия кончилась когда ты читаешь не
пони глаза читают но ты не понимаешь угу
тексты не понимаешь глаза читают но ты
тексты не понимаешь соответственно есть
два способа восстановить ментальную
энергию первый способ - это смена
фокуса когда ты занимаешься там условно
рафтинг или баги ты едешь Ты должен на
другое смотреть либо это расфокус полный
расфокус полный расфокус хорошо работает
когда ты смотришь на огонь на реку когда
ты ни о чём не думаешь смотришь на всё
но ничего не Дума лёг и подкаст Да лёг и
на небо смотришь Просто и ни о чём не
думаешь Вот этот расфокус хорошо
восстанавливает ментальную энергию А по
поводу здесь подмету это не относится к
тому что вот когда мы что-то читаем если
мы не понимаем то мы одно слово не
поняли это же Рон Харт вот это Его же
методология буде это чучуть другое Да
там это из книги учись учи
Рона харта кстати крутой мыслитель и
тоже рекомендую прочитать книгу книга
называется учись учиться Рон Харт
А это есть такое но когда ты читаешь
отчёты которые каждый день читаешь или
вещи которые тебе известны Ну это
неприменимо ты просто реально устаёшь я
потом замечаю за собой иногда вот так
работаешь раз Пошёл в туалет вроде
пятиминутное дело а я по пути ещё в окно
посмотрел кофе себе налил и так далее И
тут то я понимаю что почитал ловлю ловлю
себя на прокрастинации ловлю на
прокрастинации
и понимаю что всё я устал и у меня сразу
приоритет первый приоритет восстановить
энергию я сразу все дела откладываю моя
задача восстановить энергию вообще
удивительную вещь я вам расскажу такую
вещь Вы знаете я для себя такое открытие
можно сказать сделал что я не делю людей
на плохих хороших я делю людей на
энергодефицит
энергопроф Вот как ты говорил с детства
люди же все Энергичные так вот с годами
некоторые люди теряют энергию становятся
хронический дефицитный энергии у них
хронический дефицит энергии И эти люди
Они негатив ками становится негатив
нытики и так далее Почему Потому что вот
себя Представь Ты пришёл с работы
уставший тебе голодный холодный ещё
замёрз тебе легко нахамить ты можешь
любого обозвать тебе легко Это ты можешь
любого обозвать любого обк что-то
сломать пнуть Хотя это требует энергии
взять молоток всё разбить знаешь есть
комната
такая комната есть на ломать такая Да
когда всё ты ломаешь и так далее да
специальная комната Прикинь мебель всё
посуда стоить тебе дают битву и ты да да
да да всё Круши Ну это же смотри энергии
то на это у тебя хватает то есть отсюда
Я вывел такой закон что в мире есть
асимметрия добра и зла для того чтобы
делать зло тебе нужен минимум энергии
для того чтобы делать добро и добиться
успеха тебе требуется очень много
энергии и вот я начал на людей
по-другому смотреть Я когда смотрю
негатив нытика человек который обвиняет
президента правительство бизнесменов
зажравшихся и так далее Я понимаю что
Бедняга у него просто нет энергии Угу У
неё просто нет энергии вот по себе по
суди ты приходишь ты можешь быть Реально
конченым негодяем если у тебя энергии
нет даже у альпинистов есть такое
правило когда они вверх идут
высота по-моему называется после
которого уже человека даже нельзя судить
он тебя Может кинуть он тебя может не
спасти там Каждый сам за себя короче и
это высота вот есть такое
понятие Поэтому с энергией связано вот
это заметьте все такие качества как
благородство вежливость
терпение Воля они все связаны только с
энергией если есть энергия у тебя эти
качества есть если энергии Нет там ты
невежливый не благородный не готов
прощать и так далее интересно с энергией
можно думать много интересных вещей так
давайте перейдём
как восполнять энергию Кто как
восполняет и вообще как увеличить свой
энергетический потенциал то есть
более ещё более энергичным человек вот
здесь такой вопрос а кому условно там до
25 до Рица вообще стоит задумываться об
этом Ну типа об энергии Ему тут работать
нужно А он тут сидит на листочке так это
физическая это такая энергия о
переправляет её сидит Там я её выиграл
ему 20
лет молодых людей у которых вообще
энергии не Я знаю людей в 20 лет которых
как овощи
ходи в компьютере сидит целыми нями
зависает Да кстати компьютер страшно
высасывает Да у меня между прочим ач Ну
я давно не играю Но когда я играл вот
там как когда только начинались всякие
вот эти игры у меня конкретно забирала
энергию у меня прямо было такое ощущение
как будто я совершаю грех Потому что ты
раз начинаешь играть 10 часов 1100 сечас
лягу спать и так до 300 ночи и такое
внутреннее ощущение что это я совершаю
харам грех поэтому я Аллаху поклялся Я
больше не буду играть игр Ну то есть
сейчас там лет 1015 на самом деле ты же
будешь отвечать за то время которое как
ты распорядился своим временем своим
телом своими способностями в исламе мало
кто знает что будет спрос за всё даже за
то что например вот есть активные люди а
вот вы говорите же есть там нытики там в
депрессиях постоянно вот у них тоже
будет наверное спрос за то что то есть
ты имел там руки ноги не занимался
спортом имел там возможности и деньги
там не
путешествовал с них будет главный спрос
Одному Аллаху известно я просто думаю
что сних будет с за
неблагодарность такой шикарный мир такое
тело совершенно у человека совершенно
тело я считаю тело мир общество мы
сейчас не как Средние века шикарно
классно живём И не только богатые в
принципе в целом все здравоохранение
есть и так далее И при этом быть
неблагодарным это конечно большо у нас
есть люди алматинцы которые на ду
там там семью я уже не говорю что детей
куда-то тоже такой момент хочу вот
обратить внимание Есть люди очень
активные То есть у них активность там
фонтаном бьёт возможности есть фантазия
есть время есть например они занимаются
саморазвитием путешествуют рыбалки охоты
там но это всё они делают с друзьями с
коллегами там с одноклассниками а
Спросишь у него ты там супругу когда
приглашал там куда-то в ресторан там или
по парку прогуляться он там руки
разводит Вот как вот здесь быть вот где
вот этот баланс
то есть ну я так представляю энергия это
как Паутина например да то есть там
семья там друзья и так далее даже если
что-то оборвалось там он держится там
твой домик Да у поука то есть где вот
баланс как вот нужно это
распределять сюда сразу вопрос от
женщины интересно от жены Какой вид
энергии больше получается эмоциональный
больше эмоционально больше эмоционально
Ну наверно здесь возникает вопрос Может
здесь ну я
Да
когда там жизнь пролетела А твой сын
например смотришь подростк на девчонку
похож например или там ка наркоман стал
да Ну это тоже твоя ответственность ты
там у тебя расфокус был ты там только с
друзьями там с коллективом и так да Ну
здесь тоже нельзя перего палку нельзя
считать что во всём виноват ты потому
что в исламе тоже говорится ребёнок -
это человек который Дан тебе на время
на время ты должен постараться его
воспитать но при этом если ты не
воспитываешь если ты вот при этом каждый
человек У него всё-таки своя судьба у
ребёнка у него
а свой удел в этом мире своё
предназначение и так далее Поэтому ты
конечно ты должен то что родители дать
накормить обуть одеть дать ему кровь а
дать воспитание своим примерам не
нотации не моралью а своим
и желательно Вот я считаю что одно из
обязанностей родителей желательно найти
ребнку то занятие которое он любит То
есть то что будет его миссией по жизни
то есть то что он любит то что у него
хорошо получается и то что нужно людям
вот в это направление ребёнка если
толкнуть то после 18 лет ты не будешь
переживать насчёт мотивации он всю жизнь
будет замотивирован и так далее Но к
солени миж
учащаются И не только дети уже взрослые
начинают теряться у нас Смотри даже
Элементарно товары придёшь покупать
зубную пасту вот для меня например поход
в магазин - это стресс сильнейший стресс
я максимум могу Шопин полчаса максимум И
то если это охотничий магазин либо
туристический магазин где там всё
покупать вещи это не знаю какой-то
стресс неимоверный я физически его пря
меня колот не знаю когда-нибудь выбирали
обои обои Нет я это делаю вобще Вот это
вообще ру Ну вот Представь у людей
сейчас появился огромный выбор А выбор
принятия решений потребляет огромное
количество энергии Мы каждый день должны
принимать огромное количество решений А
любое принять решение - это очень
энергоёмкое мен инфлюенсеров блогеров
инфлюенсеров Потому что люди устают от
принятия решений и делания они дела вусо
отдают они думаю я буду париться вот
человек которого я люблю уважаю Он носит
такие кроссовки Я тоже такие буду всё
Нафиг мне самому идти там 100 500000
кроссовок для бега для ходьбы для ходьбы
на цыпочках для ходьбы на пятках для
ходьбы
нафиг хочу вернуться вот к этой истории
по поводу распределения энергии это тоже
У нас по сути вот говорит про колесо
баланса у нас Если так посмотреть на су
уже вообще расписано как доже делать
во-первых мы знаем что учёные и всегда
говорили самый лучший путь - это путь
срединный золотой средины То есть ты по
идее должен распределить энергию так
чтобы всем хватало мы знаем людей кто
там только читал намаз например всю ночь
там в тахаджуд и приходили жёны и
жаловались что вот мой муж Он только
постится например или только читает
намаз и таким людям было сказано что там
день пости день отдыхай день молись день
проводись семьёй потому что у твоего
тела есть на тебя право у твоей жены
есть на тебя право у твоих детей есть на
тебя право поэтому это вот вопрос Да вот
к убеждениям опять-таки если у тебя в
убеждениях есть что ты действительно
должен придерживаться там середины
золотой что ты должен право каждому
отдавать там своей жене своей семье там
своей религии и так далее Тогда наверное
тебе будет проще Вот в этих штуках
лавировать скажем так между энергиями
как-то так наверное да ну для меня это
уровень ценностей твоих которые Ты для
себя определяешь Зачем ты живёшь если мы
означа еся ключевому слову чтобы что Для
чего ты живёшь то у тебя есть
определённые чёткие ценности которые для
тебя важны а в них опять заложена твоя
миссия И когда ты с этим определился то
ты знаешь что оно у тебя состоит из
семьи из твоих личных предназначений из
окружений из родителей и ты Направляешь
эту всю энергию во всё что для тебя
важно да про восполнение Да извиняюсь то
что перебил из того что тоже вот мне
своё время помогало мы вот какие-то
такие тоже банальные вещи условно
менять экран телефона там после 9:00
вечера чтобы синий свет меня
потому что Учёные доказали что Синий
свет монитора
он притупляет выработку твоего гормона
сна То есть ты у тебя если синий экран
тея светит у тебя меньше гормона сна
Поэтому человек когда за компом сидит по
ночам он не чувствует время он может всю
ночь проиграть потому что у него просто
гормон цена не вырабатывается я вот там
в 9:30 у меня автоматически на всех
устройствах будь то там телефон iPad там
синий меняется на жёлтый потом
Да вот тоже в питание это вообще просто
для меня было открытие в своё время
когда я там в суде отказался жил и мне
надо было сесть на протокол я отказался
от сахара сел на жёсткую диету где-то
там 180 дней вообще не употреблял сахар
только ягоды Я заметил как сильно
во-первых кожа почистила там прыщи
какие-то ушли я был в шоке Я думаю
Ничего себе И когда я перестал есть
сахар первые 2 недели у меня была
страшная ломка башка раскалывать ужасно
Мне было тяжело я прям чувствовал лень и
я думал Неужели думаю вот эта
внутри меня сильнее чем я просто из
из-за питания из-за того тех грибов
которые ты там кормишь внутри они тобой
управляют И когда я перестал есть вот
фастфуд перестал есть сахар Я заметил
что и сон стал лучше ты просыпаешься
чувствуешь себя бодрее когда там
сократил количество даже там мяса
которое ты потребляет не каждый день
потому что раньше-то это вообще было
люди шокова там раз в недельку дай Бог у
них было мясо какое-то а у нас каждый
приём пищи мясо а его же надо как-то
переваривать с ним же нужно что-то
делать И вот еда - это тоже вот огромный
источник который может из человека
высасывать энергию вот тоже такие
лайфхаки которые вот по себе не то что
высасывать мы как раз у нас третья часть
как восполнять энергию и как увеличивать
потенциал вот больше к этому относится Я
думаю вот питание режим дня и ночи Вот
это очень важно ночной сон я бы сюда
добавил обязательно голодовку я бы сюда
добавил бы обливание холодной водой это
всё увеличи ва эти физическая активность
тоже Ну когда вот оразу держишь даже да
организм меся отдыхает у тебя сразу
ощущается вот эта голодовка Ну при
условии что ты держишь разу как
положено я не знаю как у вас но у
казах д тоя два тоя утром той вечером
той утром потому что той преддверии
голодовки А вечером той Потому что ты
держал
голодовку я я бы хотела сюда сейчас
добавить с позиции Вот именно женской Я
встречаюсь работаю очень много с
женщинами и я вижу как у них им трудно
восполнять энергию когда очень много
страхов Вот именно придуманных собой
страхов и какой-то внутренней
самокритики практически каждая вторая
женщина которая работает со мной Я
понимаю что там очень много надуманные
страхов самокритики и которые забирает у
них эту энергию и и им очень трудно её
восполнять потому что она их держит и
там
да да они выдуманные больше всего и чаще
всего это вот эта самокритика меня
недостаточно я недостаточно хороша как
жена как мать Как там не реализовано и
вот это сст да вот уходит в самокритика
самокритика идт делает не самокритика и
страх это во Это наверно связано
всё-таки с нашими какими-то половыми
различиями потому
что женщины реально много боятся Вот
почему я заметил женщина женщина хорошо
используют как риск менеджеров они в
любой возможности видят риск мужчины в
любом риске видят возможности женщины
наоборот вот из-за этого дольше они
живут Я бы сказала бы что я лично сама
восполняют измеряю своё состояние сейчас
во мне много радости или отсутствие
радости и у меня все практики направлены
наво восполнение себя радостью то есть я
иду и прогулка музыка хорошая кни га там
какие-то мои есть час полтора личного
времени ранним утром а потом только я
уже с этой радостью бужу всю свою семью
и делюсь с нею с этой радостью то есть
самое у меня Ключевое фильтр я радостна
или Я не радостна витами ливая женщина
счастливая семья Да не в отношении
радости кстати радости и счастья У меня
есть лайфхак с баги туров
Я когда первый день мы встречаемся Мы
ужинаем завтра батур и
я как интро говорю про две вещи ребята
говорю управляйте своими ожиданиями
потому что Мы двигаемся с точки А в
точку б и как бы мы всё не предусмотрели
мы всё предусмотреть не можем поэтому
управляйте своими ожиданиями второе
управляйте своим настроением потому что
вы своим
настроением чёрт с ним если это было бы
только ваше вы влияете на всех
остальных и даю лайфхак Как управлять
настроением Дело в том что управление
настроением - Это чисто выбор когда
утром просыпаетесь первым делом Задайте
себе вопрос Задайте себе вопрос я этот
день хочу провести радостно Или как
получится и самое интересное когда ты
утром себе говоришь Я хочу этот день
провести радостно в течение дня каждый
раз когда ты кукси ты вспоминаешь свой
выбор и говоришь Я же выбор
сделал провести день радостно независимо
от того что сегодня случится такой раз
себе восстанавливаешь настроение Поэтому
я считаю вот радость это твой выбор если
ты утром его не сделал то
в течение день сложится Ну как попало
вот это как раз инструмент осознанности
когда ты себе говоришь я решил провести
этот день радостно интересно витамины
ещё вот с точки зрения Вот я говорю Ну
это к питанию наверное ба витамина То
есть можно сдать анализы пойти
посмотреть как ты вообще на гормональном
уровне потому что у тебя действительно
реально может быть нехватка каких-то Ну
важных там гормонов веществ и
посредством вот изза того что сейчас Осо
рассматриваем Что нужно делать чтобы
расширить потенциал энергетический
Да это питание сер сказал это сон
восьмичасовой наверное самый лучшей с
10:00 вечера до 6:00 Да а
сон Дамир добавил физический упражнение
а четвёртое мы сказали что с утра надо
выбор делать в пользу радости плюс БАДы
свежий воздух свежий воздух у нас те с
вами ассоциация с воздухом свежий воздух
а я бы ещё добавил то что помогает вам
выбрасывать правильные гормоны это
холодная вода
экстремальные виды деятельности если это
мужчины экстремальные виды деятельности
всё равно мужик есть мужик ему надо
что-то экстремальное чуть-чуть чтобы
выбрать тестостерон адреналина был а
потому что в тепличных условиях всё
равно будет не то что мы можем ещё чтобы
расширить энергетически давайте для
женщин специально добавим убирать
напряжение с тела максимально расла
тело вот прямо для женщин спа Ну
даже даже можно сделать йогу нид вот
просто дома на 15-20 минут включить йога
нид это тотальное расслабление тела и
после этого такой объём энергии
повышается потому что очень часто в
напряжение ходит а из-за напряжения
трудно восполнится энергией поэтому для
женщины прямо нужно предписать
расслаблять тело короче лайфхак такой
получается отвер что всегда ловите себя
Каждый раз когда вы напряжены вы теряете
энергию Вот это
соответственно где бы вы ни были на
переговорах выступаете что вы не делаете
поймали себя в напряжении знаете что у
вас там идёт бешеная утечка энергии рала
Тесь Да правильно вот хороший лай так
свежий
воздух хорошая детская книжка Но на
самом деле ещё и я думаю окружение
окружение да хорошая компания
единомышленников Вот например у нас там
тоже есть практика с Этот бизнес
завтраки оттуда выходишь заряженный там
вот мой
одноклубника мы вместе тусуемся что-то
тут где-то у тебя посмотришь блин и вот
вот это реально заряжает поэтому
например хорошее общество
единомышленников Да это это классно ты
подметил недаром в народе есть такой
высказывание роскош человеческого
общения Бывает такая ситуация когда ты
попадаешь в среду когда ты общаешься и
прямо до каждой клеточки кайфуешь и вот
э среда ты правильно очень заметил среда
имеет большой значение она и на
ментальном и на духовном уровне То есть
когда например твоё окружение там
состоит из верующих людей тебе тоже ты
на них смотришь и тоже хочется быть
похожим потому что там где говорят про
Аллаха туда спускаются Ангелы Да
например да Поэтому ты знаешь к слову Об
этом я сидел тоже вот Имам который вот
на с Поклонной горы Асхат Я говорю
Можешь мне подсказать ану Да ты про
Ого их родственник просто вот Ну в общем
я с ним тоже как-то эфир проводил и он
учился в Сади такой очень прям набожный
классный мужик я говорю как ты
поддерживаешь тону свою религиозность
потому что мы знаем что Вера
увеличивается уменьшается я говорю Вот
что ты делаешь Какие практики вот именно
как религиозный человек и он говорит я
знаешь гори это вот слову контексте он
говорит я когда фар как Имам провожу я
Говори чувствую что я сею по-другому
энергии больше когда говорит не провожу
чувствую энергии меньше то есть контекст
Да мелочь Казалось бы которая плюс он
говорит то что я постоянно провожу уроки
то есть он вот вынужден у него есть
миссия скажем так даже если он не хочет
но он проводит Он говорит это для меня
становится напоминанием и каждый раз
из-за этого да там моя Вера становится
больше то есть контекст люди какая-то
практики дисциплинированные которую ты
делаешь Даже если ты не хочешь но ты
знаешь что тебе это лучше для тела лучше
Там для религии это в итоге даёт свой
эффект и то что он говорит конечно
поминание То есть если с точки зрения
религии сказать это то что раньше люди
постоянно же поминали неважно там утро
день вечер Они читали поминания и все
вот все эти вещи про энергию про лень
про удел они всё же это просили
постоянно и и чувствовали себя
по-другому Да вот иногда смотришь
думаешь Как вот они такую жизнь жили А
вот практиковали такие вещи вот с точки
зрения окружения просто Забавно как быт
как он отражён да с точки зрения как это
и в религии работает религия вообще
Ислам Я всегда говорю что Ислам - это
одна из самых самых эффективных
технологий проживания счастливой жизни
даже такой простой пример вроде
предназначения мне говорят в чём вот
смысл предназначения с точки зрения
эффективности Я говорю Смотрите если вы
хотите жить счастливе это в хадисах
говорится преимущество предназначения в
том что если у тебя а что-то не
получилось Ты говоришь на всё в воле
Аллаха и избавляет
тво или от само поедания того что у тебя
не получилось в тоже время ты
уповает говоришь иншалла получится да ты
избавляя от беспокойства за будущее то
есть основное разрушителя счастья - это
сожаление о прошлом и беспокойство за
будущее предназначение оно убирает и то
и тоты знае здесь если у меня полу
виноват на Т воле Аллаха ты ты такой раз
чувство вины А если бы я так сделал Блин
надо было вот так сказать если бы так
сказал бы то получилось бы блин зря я
тогда вот это ему не сделал кучу мыслей
а тут ты просто говоришь а всё воля
Аллаха не получилось значит так и должно
было быть всё списал в то же время не
паришься по поводу будущего слишком
сильно ты говоришь иншалла будет воля Ну
причину создаёшь
Просто если к практикам добавить ЕС
брать физические там а какие-то
эмоциональные и так далее над которым я
фокус Постоянно работает духовно а душа
же у нас вот даже колесо баланса же есть
там же пишешь же там семья там спорт и
так далее и всегда там есть духовность и
каждый духовность по-своему понимает для
меня духовность Я понимаю что у меня
есть тело которое требует пищу условно
Да вот питание требует но есть и душа
которая требует тоже пищу душа требует
пищу - это знание когда я получаю знания
именно духовные знания тогда я уже
наполняю вот этой энергией яже там
пятикратный намаз Почему я к этому
пришёл и я со временем начал задаваться
вопросом почему пять раз И вот получил
этот ответ 5 лет 5 лет на раз 5 лет
назад а почему пять раз потому что
утренний намаз он такой короткий да Там
два раката Ты только встаёшь Ты только с
мыслями собираешься самый длинный а и
долгий Намаз - это обеденный намаз Да
это когда ты там в рутине бегаешь
Бегаешь и тебе нужно остановиться и
подумать и тебя останавливает подумать
Вот это и допустим там АСР Да он такой
короткий и вечерний когда ты должен весь
день проанализировать Не зря Там было
пять раз так сделано и вот а ну вот
последний год я до этого четыре Я как-то
читал там на автоматически что-то изучал
и вот последний год У меня перешёл
какой-то на уровень осознания духовности
Вот сознани и я вот год назад прописал
дуа У меня есть дуа Такой прямо мощный
дуа - Это мой инструмент когда говорят
что ты вы движет Я говорю у меня есть
дуа дуа - это вот а как перевести для
зрителей молитва Да извинись молитва для
зрителей Вот и у меня в заметках только
дуа есть по принципу и в этом Дуа я всё
проговариваем и получается так что
например я там у меня до обеда бывает
такой раз ть негатив уходит уходит я раз
себе на мысли ловлю хорошие всё иду
намаз читаю дуа делаю как будто у меня
такой знаете вот убеждение Да как можно
сказать тако купо это купо вот этого
Кокон тако Кокон Да я такой типа
Бессмертный я такой у меня всё дела
потому что я там прописываю там о
Всевышний там всемогущий Аллах там лишь
тебе поклоняюсь там тебя восхваляют ну
там Да есть свой принцип и там дай мне
нужных людей Дай мне нужную силу энергию
и получается так вот даже вот этот
приведу Ман Клич я должен был по идее
давно познакомиться там на номера
пригласили там Арман Джамба таса
пригласили не получалось жа что
приглашал не получалось потом мы должны
были в Уральск Пятнадцатого числа
полететь вот в составе вашей группы там
Алмаз я должен был все полететь не
получилось полететь потом мне на кайзен
приглашали мероприятие Я был в Астане не
получалось Я вот вчера сижу в мегацентре
и вот не совт меня вчера вечером пишут я
вот сижу и вот говорю Вот почему так
Всевышний делает что как будто смо Коли
встретился может быть это я не должно
быть что я сейчас должен встречаться и
просто вот вот реально вот мысль такая
была через 7 минут ваша помощница мне
пишет через 7 минут подкаст я такой
думаю это фейк что ли думаю как так я
только что 7 минут назад об этом подумал
Ну типа вот я ещё вот так
проанализировал ещё сижу Там люди я
говорю вот так с мором колюче не могу
встретиться Уральск не пошёл кзн не
пошёл Почему так Может быть не судьба
они говорят Ну не знаю И тут через 7
минут я говорю смотрите сообщение они
говорят Как так Ты что шутишь что ли Я
говорю Вот сообщение смотрите говорю и
выпуск Я говорю всё согласен говорю это
Это наверное это наверное та ситуация
когда вот когда мальчик Тони корабль
подплывает да там Бог спасёт там вот
типа такой ситуации Наверное я говорю не
не я все дела Сегодня откинул говорю Нет
это вот это может быть Всевышний
проверяет насколько мне это надо Может
быть я могу на слова говорить Да может
быть наилучший способ знакомства
Всевышний способ
знакомства потом ты знаешь это же вопрос
такой Я размышлял также же о везении Что
такое везение Да а не небольшого отличее
от нашей основной темы Ну существует два
вида везения одно случайное везение
Слепое я называю а второе везение
закономерное Да И вот у меня есть
расшифровка слова везение везение - это
благоприятное стечение временных и
пространственных
обстоятельств благоприятное стечение
временных и пространственных
обстоятельств так вот в твоём случае э
видишь временное обстоятельство Аллаху
лучше видать э когда теб тебе Тебя
познакомить со мной когда и где две вещи
временные и пространственные
обстоятельства поэтому видишь во всех
других ситуациях было бы не то что-то не
сложилось бы вот даже вот не совру Вот
видите у меня Дайте мне нужных людей для
достижения цели вот о всемогущий вот всё
я его пять раз в день читаю Это мо моя
практика и там есть такой момент там у
менят последний момент вот чтоб не
соврать А вот есть последний момент
видите благодарности благодарю
Всевышнего за милость за очередной день
и так далее И вот благодарность Я как-то
до этого делал это вот есть даже
практики психологи там на своём языке
преподают там пиши Дени благодарности
Это же всё с религии взято же потом уже
перефразирует по-своему и уже появляется
там психологи условно Да сейчас
психологи не захейтили
получается к чему я рассказываю к тому
что там есть благодарность и вот когда я
благодарю у меня внутри вот знаете такое
внутренняя какая-то радость
щепетева горю там за за очередное
знакомство Я прямо Это радостный и
просто я понял что Чем больше
благодаришь тем больше появляется
поводов для благодарности Это абсолютно
чётко Хорошо ты подметил для И что ты
что человек ты становишься благородный
Ты же Всевышнего благодаришь Потому что
есть же такой даже Хадис да А вкратце
расскажу может быть поправите не
поправите шайтан подходит всевышнему и
Всевышний его хочет отправить в Ад Ну
вкратце расскажу пове в ад отправить и
шайтан говорит не отправляй меня в ад
Отправь меня на Землю я покажу что твои
люди грешны он говорит коне Да я говорит
я знаю что они грешны ве Да их даже
пророк Сахи Салям самый идеальный
человек был грешным ты думаешь они не
будут грешить но знаю говорит я буду их
прощать до тех пор пока они будут у меня
просить от Сва просить Ключевое и вот
просить что вопрос я прошу с первого там
нужных людей а потом ещё и благодарю не
так что я типа вот только забираю А
благодарю что вы мне это дали и не
забываю и вот вот эта благодарность это
вот причём знаешь как ответил же он
говорит и ты увидишь что многие из них
окажутся не благодарными это да Вот в
суре то что сам дьявол говорит что ты
говорит многих из них найдёшь
неблагодарных Ну вот да я просто вот
Хороший ты подметил благодарность очень
сильно расширяет энергетический
потенциал Вот это точно вот когда ты чем
больше ты благодаришь тем больше ты
наполняешь энерги конечно Представьте
негатив Он же не будет благодарить Вот
это свойство негатив ков нытиков они не
благодарят никого вот никого а вы
благодарите и Всевышнего и людей
окружение вокруг команду всех заметите
такую вещь в успешных странах когда
выходят к микрофону выступающие будь-то
Оскар вручение будь-то греми и так далее
у них 80% речи - это благодарность
благодарю там вот благодарю маму
благодарю папу благодарю там дочь сына
благодарю оператора благодарю ещё
благодарю это и думаешь к рече переходи
Мужик
там всё спасибо повышение
энергии расширение энергии вот есть
такое ещё такой агрегированный критерий
где говорят что уровень развития нации
определяется уровнем доверия в
обществе и второе - это уровне
благодарности вот доверие и
благодарность - это те показатели
которые в целом повышает общество Если
хотите чтобы мы жили в хорошем
обществе то прежде всего обращайте
внимание Дорогие наши зрители именно на
эти вещи это общечеловеческие вещи они
помогают всем и нет энергии всех Даже
когда человек благодарит хочется ему
что-то больше сделать вот хочется с ним
общаться Вот сразу вот это к нему
открывается даже вот а одно из вы знаете
человек Неблагодарный нарушает один из
главных принципов вообще мироздания он
принцип справедливости а нарушает это
карается на всех уровнях будь то хоть
карма хоть на духовном уровне хоть На
физическом на денежном и так далее
поэтому не будьте не благодарными в
исламе про это в Коране просто на каждой
странице не будьте не благодарными это
самое такое плохое я считаю которое
есть чтобы быть благодар нам
казахстанцам нам нужно съездить в
Индию вот после Индии ты приезжаешь и
понимаешь что мы в Алмате в
Казахстане Это
правда на те кто вы а
Теда Ну потом здесь же вопрос такой что
недаром в исламе поощряется путешествие
когда человек когда путешествует он
смотрит на мир созданный Аллахом видит
другие миры другие нации другие страны у
него более объективная картинка у него
больше поводов для благодарности мне вот
здесь цитата нравится человек
путешествует Не потому что богатый он
богатый потому что путешествует классная
фраза я у тебя её су и вот богатство все
понимают именно деньгах но богатство же
разное же духовное Ты смотришь что-то да
ценишь начинаешь вот сравнивать именно
богатство А многие это финансово это
видит Хотя богатство на самом деле это
же большое слово в плане там духовности
там ценностей
каких-то
Итак друзья у нас тайминг Мы можем
говорить конечно очень долго тем более
тема энергии она такая с одной стороны
это очень вкусная Тема а с другой
стороны она настолько обширная что
удаётся поместить в рамки там подкаста и
так далее здесь мы как бы больше дали
пробник вот
как сыры дают там Попробовать
зубочистками там Попробуй попробуй
разных сортов вкусов и так далее Также
мы сегодня потрогаю тему со всех сторон
мы может быть её полностью не раскрыли
Но мы её
потрогать дали вам подевали тема Очень
вкусная тема очень большая обширная о
ней можно говорить и говорить но Я даю
маленькую надежду что Вот наши Подкасты
будут таким зерном или закваской для
ваших разговоров на кухне Вот это очень
важно Вы тратите очень много времени
впустую говоря на кухне о политике о том
какое будет следующее решение Путина что
там с войной и так Да прекратите
обсуждать то что не находится в вашей
власти это кстати один из огром
источников потери вашей энергии вы
говорите и переживаете за то что не
можете изменить лучше займитесь
конкретными вещами вот в данном случае
вот мы говорили об энергии Соберите
своих друзей соберитесь членов семьи
пообсуждали про энергию пообсуждали
сами даже можете сесть с бумажкой и
сесть и подумать какие люди у вас
забирают энергию энергию Какие ситуации
забирают энергию Какие действия забирают
энергию В какое время у вас наибольше
потеря энергии и так далее Вы даже
можете сами сидеть и размышлять над этой
темой и эта тема она благодарная она вас
отблагодарит и вы приобретёте
дополнительную энергию А все успехи в
этой жизни зависят напрямую только от
энергии потому что я повторял повторюсь
я много раз говорил что я видел много
успешных людей а среди них я видел много
не умных но ни одного не видел не
энергичного
все успешные люди все Энергичные Но не
все успешные люди умные поэтому не
переоценивать ум и не недооцениваете
энергию займитесь своей энергией и
будьте успешны и счастливы сегодняшним
нашим спикером большая благодарность что
приехали пришли отозвались поговорили
Мне было очень приятно с вами
побеседовать
Спасибо Спасибо
большое E